بارقه امل تلوح في الافق من جده السعوديه
حول امكانيه وقف اطلاق النار في السودان
مصادر الدبلوماسيه كشفت للعربيه لان طرفي
الصراع سيوقع عن اتفاقا مبادئ بين الطرفين
يلتزمان من خلاله بهدنه انسانيه هذه انباء
تعزز التصريحات الاخيره للناطق باسم
العمليه السياسيه خالد عمر يوسف عن اقتراب
مساعي مباحثات جده من ان تكلل بالنجاح
بدورها كانت وكيله وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه فيكتوريا نولاند قد كشفت بان
المفاوضين الامريكيين المشاركين في
محادثات جده يشعرون بتفاؤل حذر
فما الذي
سيتضمنه اتفاق اطلاق وقف اطلاق النار في
حال التوصل اليه اذا بهذا الخصوص كشفت
تسريبات من مفاوضات جده عن بنود الاتفاق
المبدئي والتي تشمل ايقاف القصف الجوي
وعوده قوات الطرفين الى مراكزهما هذا الى
جانب انسحاب كل القوات المسلحه للطرفين من
العاصمه ويتضمن الاتفاق ايضا التزام
الطرفين بفتح الممرات الامنه لافساح
المجال لعمليات الاغاثه كما يقضي الاتفاق
المبدئي ان تتواصل المباحثات بين الجانبين
بمشاركه القوى المدنيه وذلك من اجل الوصول
الى اتفاق نهائي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات